sono un po sì
[Musica]
nella mia porca eva di scrivania c'è un
porca eva di spigolo che ogni volta che
inizia i video [ __ ] la vodka zoccolo
lloyd a tirano ginocchiata che moderna
rovescio monitor da tutti ragazzi e
prevenute nessuno video sono fargetta
gestiamo il nuovo videogame con questa
roba che si chiama scolapasta 2.0 oppure
puoi vedere quando sei cinta lo metti
nella vagina e ti dice se hai un figlio
probabilmente se riesci a infilatelo non
l'avrei più quale a questi risparmi kyat
e le figaro
eccoci qua ragazzo ali siano sud est
simulator halloween teaser che sarebbero
dice il nome un simulatore di morte nel
senso che dovrei morire vabbè press 21
era io sono femmina proprio uno lo
stesso che bel collo che ho ciao zio che
xe a sono lega sono legato al numero
prefetto scorta frate e questo è un
simulatore di morte non lo sai cosa vuol
dire che yuri morì massei batman dove
c'è un pipistrello che no no no no no no
no no no no no manco per il pene non
serio cazzo rini ci stavano mortacci tua
[ __ ] bauer la quale i cortei i
coltelli vanno bene basta e non mi tiri
l'inizio i ragni non no sembra però sti
cazzi fosse lanciata in un anch'io prono
a tirare no ti chiedo cortesemente di
non sbagliarmi la sacca palacer
ripensandoci va bene fa il cazzo che
vuoi e nava che le 8 obbliga ma beccato
lo sterno claudo ma sto idea a bere
lezzi 106 no no no
[Musica]
e stata una sensazione orribile orribile
thanks for plaining tua madre marcatura
ma [ __ ]
cos'è a zio ha bisogno si è finito crede
sinceramente invece no ai dei capezzoli
che ti giuro mia rapano ma la cosa che
hai fatto prima mi ha fatto malissimo
sentite e guarda contiamoci siato 1234
facciamo one direction cosa avete in
serbo per il buon favi che sono qui
tranquillo
aes con il simulatore di morte ti fa
vedere cosa c'è dopo la morte un cazzo
avete però mica visto che continuava a
guardare perfetto ragazzi sono su nel
mondo dei dinosauri che è bello ma che
la schiavo che si fa questa roba forza e
bach e figo no vabbè sta cosa con law
chiuse ed è pazzesca
mica e non ci posso credere ciao sono
fatto ciao zio non è una di quelle
donald vieni vieni al mcdrive offro io
oggi facciamo frittelle di uova e ne 80
di voi ragazzi avete un acchiappa mosca
e per caso
mi fa schifo e ve lo dico mi fa
veramente schifo tra gli stand nerd non
siamo se peggio te ne vai ragazzo grazie
è andato via è andato via perfetto
perfetto no non va bene la di stronzo
importante che non mi tocchi nel
sentimentale zio
ok bisogna fare quasi precisa sto fermo
perché volare i piccioni cosa succede a
zio solo qua mi protegge dall intero
no no io non sono qui sono sono una
marionetta ia ia l'accesso è bello ciao
fido come stai lì stare in una bomba per
la tua minchia credimi sei un alito che
stacca zio ma tranquillo e questo non
solo non sono due verrà presto con
colucci dando il servizio gratis e per
carità non web gratis
faccio io muovo anche per questa tela
riparo se per caso ha intenzione di
mangiarmi sappi che non c'è sono
piccante piace il piccante passata tua
suocera frate è bravo a torna dopo io
intanto pulisco che cazzo è appena
successo ragazzi posso uscire ma mi sono
veramente prendendo malissimo
non è che per caso qualche ragno
preistorico che non il crime sul loculo
swift ciao
che bello tutto pulito fantastico mi
piacerebbe a mia madre pressi space
iniziamo ragazzi non ho ancora capito
cos'è ragazze ma non a questo e
l'autobus della scuola rega andiamo a
scuola avrà chiaro questo lo so ma suo
gesù arriva prendimi premi mi puzza una
cella
motivo la facciata ma beccato in pieno
il naso sono morto no non sono morto
ciao fuori genere chi siamo
li mortacci tua madre che ti ha fatto
così brutto appello è tema anche alle
gambe e non si vola nelle stanze senza
per indossare che maleducazione ma posso
muovermi io devo stare fermo a guardarlo
volteggiare non tanto mai più a farmi
prendere si spaventi lungo
ma io no no no no no io nella mattonella
non c entrano senza permesso non entra
nessuna parte di portarci vostri così
che siamo entrati in star wars ragazzi
del porno così ma qualcuno la voglia di
spiegarmi il senso visto gioco perché
ancora non l'ho capito bravi fatto
centro complimenti importante che non mi
becco un ferro in faccia poi quello che
vuoi va bene cosa dovrebbe mai succedere
se continua così
oddio schivate tutta mi sento che fu
allora che ha una volta ho fatto un
sogno simile erano figata calcio sembra
di volare e bellissimo più miglior gioco
per oculus rift di sam della vita dove
sei ma cibo dove sei di fico cazzotto in
bocca
questo andando sul piano piano sono
ragazzi sono diventato un esperto di
centrare i buchi cosa che non è semplice
lo posso garantire
lo sai chi è vero principe di sayanim un
tender tema con la volta di una montagna
in faccia ridonerà è una barretta di
cereali una barretta di cioccolata
allora porta permesso uno mi stimi io
non ho ancora capito un cazzo di quello
che sto giocando di capitolare ci sono
bambini che volano volo io soffre di
alitosi
salve no non stai fermo stai ferma ferma
e qualcuno che bussa arrivo c'è il
campanello è comunque volendo poi sarà
anche quello per me sì madonna che diamo
una verniciata sicuri e anche potresti
darli al no c'è la maniglia puoi aprire
con la maniglia non ho fa il cazzo che
vuoi ho detto fai il cazzo che vuoi io
torna indietro se è la madonna su così
brucia sempre pronto a tutto
e ce ne vuole perché io sono proprio
brutto ma tu cccp dai dentro
va beh no un organo lui no lui no
crediti delle gambe
sei brutto
non energetica cos'è sera è la mossa di
[ __ ] me non farmi volare potere
nel loro a chiave del trasporto come
goku non lo so avete di che bolo ragazzi
non lo sto capendo una sega ha visto
gioco ma va bene sembra il viaggio che
uno spermatozoo fa nella vagina quindi
sono uno spermatozoo sono uno sperma
salve hai capito come aprire le porte o
sei ancora incazzato e ancora incassato
che lasciamo lì tranquillo che ora va
abbiategrasso e al della la prima a
sinistra li mortacci sua sbagliato vabbè
andava fiumicino dai già qualcosa
puoi andarci a fiumicino signor non
vuole andare a finire la torniamo ad
abbiategrasso succhiami le palle
avessero scherzando su statuto sto
scherzando
ma cosa vi spiego come vi chiedo è di
che s'è allontanato per a funzionare da
ad essere avanti negli horror
se qualcuno pixel usate il pieno pieno o
cazzo funziona cioè rafficato a sta cosa
del genere non scorretta prima mezz'ora
di cotta hai finito di seguirmi ha
finito di seguirmi che bello
no non ha finito di seguito ascoltami
ascoltami ascoltami
no no no è inutile che molti a delfino 6
pelato e chi me lo ripaga loculo sade tu
sei tutto regalo è una merda tanto
meglio
è finito così c'era un cazzo di bambino
che volteggiava per aria
c'è uno che tira testate alle cose che
non ho capito perché e c'è un cristo
stavo scherzando quando dicevo che do
regalarmelo pure sta meglio ma comunque
l'invenzione dei piedi risale a qualche
centinaio di anni fa quindi potreste
anche usarli dai giorno ragatzu alibi
cappellini testimoniano il fatto che per
oggi basta colloquio slip e cos'è sembra
che io stia perdendo i capelli e
tristissima sa cosa che cosa stranissima
comunque ragazzi di un primo che
l'episodio con sei video è piaciuta
sotto commento è un mi piace anche a
faccia di facebook e come nei video
trattando tizianesco sera si discute ci
vediamo possibili bella ragazza